question for you guys i'm gonna go to
you okay
so uh uh you remember when we used to
buy newspapers and everybody would read
newspapers
some years ago newspapers boom gone
nobody's buying newspapers magazines
dogs are just pissing on carpets all
over america so so go to blackberry go
to newspaper go to any of that stuff
right okay they're gone we don't even
use black
next health remember people next time we
used to do all this stuff okay
10 years from now
20 years from now let's go 2041 okay
you got ufc
you got mma
is there going to be one that's going to
be forgotten about and the other one's
going to surpass the other one like
there's going to be a major separator
between the two sports or both boxing
and mma are going to be around ufc is
going to be around 20 years from now ufc
will i guarantee will be around boxing
needs to figure things out boxing's the
one who are in trouble i think that and
that's another
thing with jake paul a plus is he's
getting that yet younger demographic
into watching boxing when before they're
not watching triple g and these guys
they don't care to be interested yeah
because their dad's probably running
into it so but everyone's kind of in the
ufc so i think ufc would be around but
boxing you know they need that next big
star because you know canelo's getting
older he's probably the biggest star you
got fury you got wilder you got joshua
but they're gonna need someone like uh
you know connor but in boxing to get
that younger audience it's not jake it's
not jake it's not logan you need someone
in traditional boxing to come up through
the rankings who has the it factor like
conor mcgregor you think a sport is
going to be disrupted like you think
there's going to be a sport that's not
prime for that
from the promoters to the way they do
things yeah think about it also you know
twelve three minute round like it's it's
it's a lot man it's cool it's very they
take six rounds to fill each other out
like it's tough man that's a good point
because you're not seeing anything
you're not seeing any action for
students right now and they don't fight
really to hurt each other anymore you're
not seeing hagglers out there anymore
they're like look let's we're going to
have a trilogy here we're going to milk
they're also killing i don't mean
interrupt you they're also killing
themselves because you have you know
four major promoters so the fights we
want to see we don't see happen for
years down the road to we're over it
yeah so they have an interesting thing
but did you hear what mayweather
recently said about the uh uh the
conversation came about when they asked
him who do you think the best
heavyweight of all time he said larry
holmes over
ali they said why larry holmes says
first of all you know ali lost to norton
three times he just kind of started
going through the whole history you know
ali didn't do this ali lost ali used to
rope a dope and you can't do that and
it's a different kind of style he used
to make people tiramisu
yeah he says to me it's larry holmes
it's not muhammad ali and then he says i
think i'm the greatest boxer of all time
and he went through the whole argument
he made about the fact that he's the
greatest boxer of all time do you have a
good argument who do you put as the
greatest boxer of all time uh floyd's
definitely up there floyd's up there i
heavyweight's tough you know when they
say you know larry holmes or muhammad
ali or mike tyson you know because
evander holyfield you'd have to rank
over mike tyson yeah but because we came
up with mike tyson i mean this big scary
guy and i love people think of him i
love mike tyson but he to me he's i'm in
the conversation for greatest all time
he was the scariest of all time when he
had his run his first yeah look at his
resume he wasn't beating anybody of note
the guys that he fought that he wasn't
allowed to bully lost to so you to me
he's not you know he's not the same
you're saying the whole thing but i mean
that's like feels the rig bows but
that's like the uh linux is better than
all wait
you put riddick ahead of tyson
i don't know if i put him ahead of tyson
but we're talking about greats yeah he
he's not he's not so he's he's in top
three or he's not he's to me he's the
scariest okay and at the time in the
promotion and in the past
around the pop culture like he's by far
the so would you would you say is it
fair to say like if we were to define it
like you know the most dominant player
in the history the nba
shack right maybe he's not the greatest
but he's the most dominant player ever
in the history of the nba is that kind
of how you're putting it yeah okay or
tim duncan yeah
tim duncan was a monster he was a
monster but shaq came in shaq would turn
the elbow hits your face you're done run
up and down the court yeah he's getting
a crap out of everybody yeah so but
going back to so who's at the top for
you
it's tough because it's it's a tough
conversation to have because you look uh
julio chavez senior you know who's like
[ __ ] 90 and so whatever 90 and 40.
that guy fought
every day and the biggest gate live gate
of all time in mexico mexico city i
think it was like 120 000 sold out he's
a profit monster yeah like i did what
are we talking about nuts
you know you look at sugar ray like it's
tough man we talk great as well fair so
let's say today top ten you put canelo
on top ten today it's has canelo already
done you know
one right now
i don't even know if i can name ten
boxers today oh oh no no that's not what
i'm asking i'm asking ten bucks canelo
amongst the history has canelo done
enough does he already have enough in
his catalog to say he is an arguably top
ten guy for sure really yeah you already
put it look at the different weight
classes that he's competing at yeah for
sure yeah and there's the star power
watching and fight i mean doing what was
that good amazing it's really really
ridiculous but again you want to see him
fight earl spence or terence crawford
different promoters so we're never going
to get by the way all i'm thinking of
right now is the scenic coming to
america it's like rocky maziana every
time you want to talk about joe lewis
you bring up rocky marciano right yeah
they won yes they won exactly that's
rocky mountains
that's where i'm at with this yeah it's
uh put rocky on the list listen
mayweather wakes up and mayweather says
i'm the greatest of all time
there's an argument he's the only one
that's undefeated is there anyone else
who's completely undefeated yeah
marciano is the other one no who's
marcelo was 40 years old he's 50 you
know something like that here we go
ladies and gentlemen rocky martial the
the difference is floyd once he got to
that level you're paying to watch him
lose and he's very defensive fighter
he was fighting off his back foot in
super defenses yeah like didn't knock
and didn't finish anybody but you know
he made it he said something he says
everybody keeps talking about i dodge
pacquiao i'm older than pacquiao yeah
you know he's like what are you dodging
the guy i'm older than the guy and i
agreed to he should have beaten me the
other way around pat here's your next
here's your next business venture and
you're gonna we're gonna partner with
thick boy studios here to make this
happen klitschko brothers did this thing
where you box one round and then you
play chess in the second round and you
either had to win by knockout or you had
to do a checkmate it's crazy thing out
there over there in ukraine they got a
lot of time on their hands but we could
do the same thing
but you're going to box one around and
then you got to come out and do a roast
battle in the second round that'd be fun
so you do a roast battle so you roast
each other and then you know you got to
box pete davis
wouldn't it work you know why it
wouldn't work have you seen this the one
audio clip of canelo that goes viral
have you seen the on tick tock the
camera call me a [ __ ]
some dogs
call me a [ __ ]
i had to say they came alive yeah so
canelo because if you did a roasting
canelo is like his eating the ability to
roast yeah triple g's can be tough as
well yeah here's that big drama show
personality yeah so that that that that
business model is out the window fairly
quickly
i don't know you got there you go but
the point is boxing needs to figure it
out there it is we're pitching those
ideas boxing
canelo canelo brought something up the
other day canelo said he said if
mayweather were to fight me at my peak
versus his peak i'd crush him that's
what canelo said do you agree with that
i agree with you yeah i'm agreeing with
canelo really huge so you think canelo's
peak beats mayweather
yeah yeah a prime canal yeah but canelo
is bigger than mayweather right they're
not the same weight class they they
fought before and he beat him but canelo
was 21 years old so floyd oh they fought
before of course but but canelo was 21
he didn't have the experience and floyd
was in his prime so he got a young like
fresh out of the gym canelo and floyd
was prime floyd
he dominated do you think you think
floyd terry does the gunner for the
first part of that their fight
uh no i think he was just downloading
the data and trying to figure it out and
connor landed some good shots but he
never really felt like he was in danger
at all he could turn it off no he did
get hit and then he was like enough's
enough and then went to work yeah that's
what i feel like you're saying but i
also felt like it was like a little like
gentleman's uh agreement i'm not gonna
put it on you the first couple rounds
here i i think he was smart and cerebral
about it and was like all right this we
know the kid has a good left hand it's
sneaking it's coming from angles we
probably haven't seen in boxing so and
that's what made floyd great like i'm
gonna download the data and then pick it
apart so those first few rounds he's
downloading the data connor landed some
nothing too crazy and then he just
[ __ ] ate him alive now logan paul on
the other hand
logan paul you i worked that so i worked
both those fights
with floyd mayweather you know i'm in
the back so i'm doing the interview so
floyd i went into floyd's training room
and he sent mitts and i was that's the
first time ever in my life i went oh he
looks
46 or whatever he is 46 years old he
looks funny i was like oh my god gray
and his bear i'm like oh this like ken
mitch i'm like he looks older man i was
like logan might have a decent shot here
now i do think there was some sort of
agreement you know not to for him just
completely
knock his ass out because even you know
i when i say i was ringside i mean like
i'm on the [ __ ] ring sitting there
watching them and while you know they're
announcing and floyd's moving
logan kept saying it's an exhibition
champ remember it's exhibition champ can
you tell me what is [ __ ]
but the problem is you're dealing with
whatever he's four i think he's 40 he's
dealing with a 46 year old man who's
floyd's time have you had him in here
floyd's tiny dude logan's a big dude man
and he's hanging on he's just awkward
what do you mean this is exhibition
what's he trying to say what what's
what's the messaging behind that i just
yeah i don't know but just like like
i think dude let's let's have some fun
you're like hey like let's have some fun
man you know that's like rocky three or
four when these other little followings
yeah hey remember it's just exhibition
it's this exhibition
but again i think you'd have to be crazy
to think that thing was all fluke and
floyd can knock him out in 30 seconds
because
it's floyd's legacy to go six rounds
with this [ __ ] youtuber it's not
great man he doesn't want that
30 seconds he would have done it man
that's what made him look great i agree
this is there's there's
there's precedent for this too though i
mean look you talked about ali look up
ali versus uh lyle alzado back in the
day lyle alzado
lyle alzado the old new year oh you
think remember that was in dempsey i do
that was when i was in denver at my high
stadium don't remember
why zeta was the reason everybody in the
world thinks steroids are bad correct
dude
110 pounds you know yeah but he had
cancer for something else but they
chalked it up to steroids what he did he
came on like you know cbs was like i
wish i i never did these things
with the wwe murdered his family
his finishing move for people don't
remember chris benoit he would jump off
the top rope and use his head to like
head back but i will tell you but i will
tell you this let's not get it twisted
you know how they say money makes you
more of what you are today if you give
when you're broke you're going to give a
lot when you're rich right sure if
you're stingy when you're broke you're
stingy when you're rich if you're a dick
when you're broke you're going to be a
rich dick is what you're going to be
right you're way better at it so i think
steroids makes you more of what you are
today like if you're saying your
brother's got a temper let's just say if
he gets on like we don't want my
steroids no no we don't want him
like if we want him decade or something
he's great we got any hecklers you'll
see him go through the crowd man yeah
when's the last time that you guys yeah
thank god you wouldn't be able to handle
this wrestle like we'll mess around
wrestle with them [ __ ] around with them
but we haven't gotten like a real fight
since we were kids jay how tall are you
man
you're six too
when did he get bigger than you when did
that happen in college oh so you had a
good run you had a good run man
yeah i remember my dad used to bully me
too my dad was a big dude and i came
back like freshman year of college and
i'm like what's up now it's so i'm not
i'm not it's old yeah
i beat him in arm oh you don't want to
leave for the first time when i was 18
and he was legitimately mad like
legitimately angry yeah listen
i can see that so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]